DENIAL COMFORT ZONE THAT IS THE
ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW WITH REACTION,
RUDY GIULIANI.
ATTORNEY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HER
HERE.
>> GREAT OPEN.
>> Laura: THERE MUST BE
REPERCUSSIONS FOR BAD ACTORS,
CHICAGO OR IN THIS CASE.
A LOT OF VICTIMS IN THIS
COLLUSION HOAX.
>> THE PRESIDENT PUTS IT BEST
WHEN HE SAYS IT CAN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN.
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN ASSURE THAT
IS TO FIND OUT WHAT HAPPENED AND
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
I THINK IT HAS TO BE CLEAR TO
ANY FAIR-MINDED PERSON THE WHOLE
IDEA OF CONSPIRACY WITH THE
RUSSIANS, INTERFERENCE WITH THE
ELECTIONS IS TOTALLY UNTRUE.
THREE INVESTIGATIONS AND NOT A
SINGLE BIT OF EVIDENCE IN EVERY
SINGLE WITNESS WHO CNN WAS A
BLOCKBUSTER FELL APART.
>> Laura: JEFF ZUCKER SAID
THAT HE HAD NO REGRETS.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO APOLOGIZE
FOR.
THEY ARE NOT INVESTIGATORS THEY
ARE JOURNALISTS.
>> MAYBE THEY DON'T HAVE A
CONSCIENCE.
HOW MANY BLOCKBUSTERS?
PAUL MANAFORT, ONE AFTER THE
OTHER, COHEN TOTALLY FELL APART.
HE HAS TO BE PROSECUTED FOR
PERJURY.
WHO DID IT!
THAT STARTED SOMEWHERE AND IT
DIDN'T COME OUT OF THIN AIR.
SOMEBODY CAME UP WITH THE IDEA
THAT THEY WOULD GET PAUL
MANAFORT AND TRUMP AND
PERPETRATED THIS HOAX AND THEN A
LOT OF PEOPLE COMMITTED A LOT OF
CRIMES.
IF YOU FOCUS ON THE BORAX OF
DAVIS, CLEAR PERJURY.
JAMES COMEY HAS TO BE BRAIN-DEAD
TO THINK THAT THE DOSSIER WAS A
LEGITIMATE DOCUMENT.
IT IS A JOKE.
>> Laura: HE ACTUALLY SPOKE
OUT BY THE WAY.
>> HE CAME OUT OF THE TREES?
>> Laura: I CAN TELL THE
REDWOOD FROM HIM.
THESE ARE THE NEW COMMENTS HE
SAID.
THE PART THAT IS CONFUSING AS I
CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE OBSTRUCTION STUFF.
I HAVE GREAT FAITH IN BOB
MUELLER BUT I CAN'T TELL WHY HE
DIDN'T DECIDE TO QUESTION THE
ENTIRE RATIONALE FOR THIS
COUNCIL IS TO MAKE SURE THE
POLITICAL AREN'T MAKING THE KEY
CHARGING DECISIONS.
>> [LAUGHS]
HE IS NOT POLITICAL?
>> Laura: HE HAS ANOTHER ONE.
HE IS HEADING BILL BARR
OBVIOUSLY.
>> TAKE A LOOK AT THE ACTIVE
DAVID.
HE PUTS FORTH THE DOSSIER IS A
REAL LEGITIMATE INTELLIGENCE
DOCUMENT.
FIRST OF ALL THEY DON'T
DISCLOSE, HE WITHHOLDS WHICH IS
PERJURY REALLY.
CERTAINLY MISLEADING THE COURT,
FRAUD ON THE COURT.
$1 MILLION WAS PAID BY THE
OPPONENT OF DONALD TRUMP.
NOT INTELLIGENCE DOCUMENT,
$1.1 MILLION CAMPAIGN DOCUMENT.
SECOND, IT HAS ABSURD THINGS
LIKE TRUMP WAS AN AGENT OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT FOR TEN YEARS
AND THEY DECIDED FIVE YEARS AGO
FROM THAT DATE THAT HE WAS GOING
TO BE PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: HE IS TOURING THE
COUNTRY ON HIS BOOK TOUR.
>> BABY HE IS THE LAZIEST GUY IN
AMERICA, WITH THE THAT MICHAEL
COHEN WAS IN PRAGUE IN A
SPECIFIC DATE.
HOW DIFFICULT IS IT TO CALL UP
THE STATE?
>> Laura: THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
CHECK IT.
>> WHY NOT?
THE WORD HE MADE WAS GROSS
NEGLIGENCE.
MAYBE HE IS GUILTY OF IT, NOT
JUST HILLARY.
THIS GUY HAS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> Laura: TO THINK HE WOULD?
>> UP HOPE SO.
I HOPE IT DOESN'T GET OFF
BECAUSE HE DOESN'T LIKE TO LOOK
AT REDWOODS.
HE PERPETRATED A FRAUD AND HE IS
EITHER GROSSLY NEGLIGENT OR WAS
ACTING DELIBERATELY.
>> Laura: WE SPOKE ABOUT SOME
DENIAL OF THE OTHER NETWORK AND
THIS WAS DON LEMAN AND CHRIS
COMEAU'S REACTION TO YOUR
INTERVIEW ON CNN LAST NIGHT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> RUDY GIULIANI I HAVE KNOWN
MOST OF MY LIFE.
WE'VE HAD PLENTY OF NASTY
BACK-AND-FORTH'S.
WE TRY TO DISAGREE WITH DECENCY.
HE DEMANDED AN APOLOGY FROM YOU
TONIGHT.
I MET WITH I SAID.
THERE IS NOT ANY APOLOGY COMING.
WE'RE TAKING A VICTORY LAP FOR
NOT BEING VILLAINS.
THAT IS HOW LOW THE STANDARD IS.
>> THAT IS PATHETIC.
VILLAINS?
ON COLLUSION HE WAS COMPLETELY
EXONERATED.
THAT IS REALLY SAD.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT SAID
THE REPORT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
BETTER.
YOU AGREE?
>> I PROBABLY DID 100 OF THOSE
AND I'VE NEVER SEEN ONE LIKE
THAT.
I CAN EXONERATE HIM, I CAN
CHARGE THEM BUT I CAN EXONERATE
HIM!
>> Laura: I THOUGHT THAT WAS
WEAK.
>> INAPPROPRIATE AND UNETHICAL.
DO NOT SUPPOSE TO SAY THAT.
>> Laura: WHY DID HE?
>> THERE ARE TWO SIDES OF
MUELLER.
THE GOOD SIDE AND THE WISEMAN
SIDE AND HE WON A FEW OF THOSE
BATTLES.
I DO THINK IT IS PATHETIC THAT
HE COULD MAKE UP HIS MIND.
>> Laura: HE COULDN'T BRING
YOU GUYS END WITH THE PRESIDENT
TO SIT DOWN BECAUSE WHY WOULD
YOU?
DID YOU EVER GET CLOSE TO
SITTING DOWN WITH THE MUELLER
TEAM?
>> WE LET THEM THINK THEY WERE.
>> Laura: YOU GUYS TRYING THEM
OUT FOR A LONG TIME WHICH I
THOUGHT WAS BRILLIANT.
>> HALF OF THEM ARE GOOD GUYS,
GOOD WOMAN AND A HALF OF THEM
ARE TOTALLY UNETHICAL
PROSECUTORS.
I WOULD'VE HIRED HIM IN
2 MINUTES IF I WAS ATTORNEY.
HE SHOULD NEVER GO NEAR A COURT
ROOM.
THE MAN IS HORRIBLE.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THEY ARE
GOING AFTER BILL BARR NOW.
FORMER HW ATTORNEY GENERAL NOW
FOR THE PRESIDENT WHO BEFORE HE
TALKED ABOUT TRUMP EVERYBODY
LOVED BILL BARR, BUT NOW LET'S
WATCH.
>> THERE WERE TWO MAJOR
CRITICISMS OF WHAT HE DID.
HE INSERTED HIMSELF IN THE
PROCESS WHEN HE DIDN'T NEED TO
AND THAT HE DID IT HASTILY.
>> THEY HANDLE THE PURE BABY TO
A POLITICAL APPOINTEE CAN LEAD
TO A NEW GENERAL WITH VERY
AGGRESSIVE VIEWS.
>> PEOPLE ON THE INSIDE DIDN'T
WANT TO TRUST HIM.
THEY WERE AFRAID HE WOULD DO
SOMETHING.
>> THERE IS NOTHING POLITICAL
ABOUT BILL BARR.
HE WASN'T AT THE TRUMP VICTORY
PARTY, WISEMAN WAS CRYING AT
HILLARY'S.
HE DIDN'T RUN THE TRUMP
FOUNDATION LIKE REID WHO WORKED
THERE AND RAN THE FOUNDATION.
THAT IS WHERE THAT IS.
BILL BARR IS A PROFESSIONAL,
LAW ENFORCEMENT GUY AND
PROFESSIONAL LAWYER.
HE HAPPENS TO BE
ATTORNEY GENERAL THE WAY MICHAEL
McKAY'S HE WAS ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
NOT THE POLITICAL OPERATIVES
LIKE CLINTON OR OBAMA HAD.
I DON'T GET IT.
IN ANY EVENT, THE DECISION WAS
MADE BY ROD ROSENSTEIN.
HE STARTED THIS INVESTIGATION.
IF YOU THINK IS GOING TO SELL
OUT ON AN OBSTRUCTION?
THE THEORY OF OBSTRUCTION IS YOU
HAVE TO GIVE A LAW DEGREE IF YOU
BOUGHT INTO THAT.
WHEN THE WHOLE INVESTIGATION
TOOK PLACE, WHAT DID HE OBSTRUC
OBSTRUCT?
>> Laura: YOU DON'T NEED AN
UNDERLYING CRIME BUT IT IS AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT.
>> YOU DON'T NEED IT, VERY
CRITICAL.
>> Laura: WHY WOULD IT TAKE
WEEKS TO GET HIS FULL REPORT
INSTEAD OF THIS?
>> THERE IS A WHOLE PITCH FULL
OF 16 MATERIAL.
>> Laura: MEANING?
>> GRAND JURY MATERIAL.
IF YOU THINK THAT BILL BARR MADE
A MISTAKE, WHAT YOU THINK
NANCY PELOSI AND ADAM SHIFT
WOULD DO?
IT WOULD BE YELLING AND
SCREAMING THAT HE SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED.
HE HAS TO BE VERY CAREFUL AND
MAYBE HE WILL GO TO A JUDGE AND
GET IT RELEASED OR MAYBE THEY
WILL TRY TO GET IT.
I WOULD LIKE THE WHOLE THING.
I'M CONVINCED WE CAN ANSWER.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT WANTS
IT OUT.
SPEAK WITH YOU READ THIS LETTER
THERE IS NO SMOKING GUN.
YOU CAN'T COME TO THE CONCLUSIO
CONCLUSION --
>> Laura: THEY ARE SAYING THAT
THERE IS OBSTRUCTION LIKE
BEHAVIOR.
>> ON A SINGLE FACT YOU DON'T
KNOW.
>> Laura: YOU HAVEN'T SEEN IT
SO HOW DO YOU KNOW?
>> YOU DON'T THINK AFTER ALL
THESE MONTHS WE HAVE A PRETTY
GOOD IDEA WHAT IS AND THERE HAVE
BEEN DEBATED?
>> Laura: ARE YOU PREPARING
FOR LET'S SAY THE BAZAAR HAPPENS
AND THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
HAS A DEATH WISH AND GOES THE
IMPEACHMENT ROAD?
ARE YOU READY FOR THAT NOW?
>> OF COURSE WE ARE.
ABSOLUTELY.
WE HAVE A VERY LONG MULTIFACETED
MEMO WRITTEN ALREADY THAT WE CAN
CUT-AND-PASTE DEPENDING ON WHAT
DAY.
THE COLLUSION PART OF IT AS A
NECESSARY NOUN.
WE CAN TAKE THAT OUT.
IF THEY WANT TO BATTLE OVER
OBSTRUCTION THEY COULD MAKE
FOOLS OUT OF THEMSELVES.
HOW ABOUT YOU BRING THE CASE
AGAINST TRUMP ON OBSTRUCTION, HE
DIDN'T DELETE 30,000 EMAILS.
HE DIDN'T BUST UP A SERVER.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A HAMMER.
>> Laura: YOU CAN INFER
INTENT?
I REMEMBER THAT IN THE LAW
SCHOOL.
>> DE DON'T THEY WANT TO DO?
THE WHOLE THEORY AND WE HAD THIS
DEBATE.
THEY WANT TO LOOK IN HIS BRAIN
AND SAY, ALTHOUGH HE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING TO OBSTRUCT
INVESTIGATION, HE WAS THINKING
ABOUT IT.
WE DON'T HAVE A BRAIN X-RAY
MACHINE TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS
ADEPTLY START A PROSECUTING
PEOPLE FOR THOUGHTS, HALF OF
AMERICA WOULD BE IN JAIL.
>> Laura: THE TOWN WOULD BE
EMPTIED OUT.
CAN DRIVE AROUND WITH NO
TRAFFIC.
SOME OF YOUR FRIENDS OF THE
MEDIA HAS HAD SOME THINGS ABOUT
YOU A FEW WEEKS AGO AND THEY
LOVE YOU.
NOW IT HAS COME UP AT THIS TIME.
WATCH.
>> DID RUDY GIULIANI HARM THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK IT HURT THE
PRESIDENT.
>> IS HE HELPING OR HURTING THE
PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
IT SEEMS TO BE HURTING UNLESS
THERE IS SOME DEEP STRATEGY I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HERE.
>> Laura: IT DEPENDS ON WHO IS
COLLUDING?
>> MAYBE THEY'RE NOT SMART
ENOUGH TO HAVE FIGURED OUT THE
STRATEGY.
I FEEL SORRY FOR THEM.
OF COURSE THERE WAS A STRATEGY
AND OF COURSE --
I CAME TO THE CONCLUSION WHEN I
CAME HERE A YEAR AGO THAT WE HAD
DEPENDED ON TWO LEVELS.
WE HAD DEPENDED LEGALLY WITH HIM
AND TO ARGUE THE LAW ON THE
FACTS AND TRY TO DELAY THEM AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE SO WE CAN BUILD
A GOOD CASE IN CASE THEY DID
GIVE US A SUBPOENA.
THEY DON'T GET THAT THEY'RE NOT
ENTITLED TO THAT.
ON THE SECOND HAND REALIZED
IMMEDIATELY WE DON'T HAVE A
JURY.
THEY WILL NOT TRY THIS TO THE
THIS WILL BE A POSSIBLE
IMPEACHMENT SO WHO IS THAT?
THE PUBLIC OPINION.
>> Laura: THAT STILL SAYS, NEW
POLL THAT CAME OUT THAT HALF OF
THE COUNTRY THINKS THAT TRUMP UP
STRUCTURED JUSTICE.
A MESSAGING PROBLEM FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THE NUMBER
WOULD BE THAT HIGH.
THAT LINE THAT MUELLER LEFT IN
THE LATTER.
>> I SAW A PULL FIVE DAYS AGO.
50% THOUGHT IT WAS A WITCH HUNT.
AS LONG AS THOSE POLES ARE
WITHIN STRIKING DISTANCE THEY
WILL NOT TEACH THEM.
TODAY EVEN ON CNN THEY WERE TWO
POLITICAL EXPERTS SAYING,
IMPEACHMENT IS OUT OF THE
QUESTION.
NANCY PELOSI GAVE YOU THE
STANDARD WHICH IS YOU HAVE TO
GET BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THERE IS NO REPUBLICAN THAT WILL
SUPPORT IMPEACHMENT.
>> Laura: WHAT DID HE DO TO
CELEBRATE?
>> NOTHING SPECIAL.
WE HAD A NICE DINNER AND A NICE
DINNER ON SUNDAY AND LUNCH ON
MONDAY.
WE FOOLED AROUND WITH THE
WASHINGTON CAPITALS.
>> Laura: I SAW THAT.
>> I GRABBED HIM AND I SAID, I
WILL DESTROY THAT PICTURE.
I WILL TAKE THAT CAMERA AND
BREAK IT AND THROW IT.
>> Laura: DID HE SAY, I WILL